Cristi you posted this on Instagram last
month it goes against my better
judgement to acknowledge haters and
conspiracy theorists but because it
involves my precious daughter I'm
setting the record straight so tell us
what needed to be set straight other
than your bones that were broken and why
are people mean well I mean I thought
that this was a plan yeah first of all
you would be the mother of the year to
break bones
[Applause]
this person thought that Dancing with
the Stars this amazing show that's been
on all these years is gonna lie that
cedars-sinai is gonna lie and go along
with it I mean it was so ridiculous I
mean huge is so bad well it at first I
wasn't even gonna respond but you know
what like any mom out there when it's
your child right you get a little riled
up
it's just indicative of what's going on
right now I just feel like in America we
just need to like love each other more
because I feel like even that's from
childhood somebody said that because
people were mean and I was like why are
people so mean and I asked I was a
church and somebody a really cool pastor
was like you know people who weren't
loved enough that's why they're mean so
you need to love them more because they
just don't even know how to reciprocate
the feeling or feel it or so it is true
love generally does heal a lot of things
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this